hey guys my name is Jess and it's the
third of every my least favorite month
to pronounce and we've only got twenty
six days left here's what mattered in
gaming rocket League is getting a new
playlist called rocket labs which will
let players try out a new map rocket
labs will be out in the upcoming for
every update so you can try out
prototype arena layouts which have a
virtual reality inspired aesthetic
player feedback will help decide which
work-in-progress maps get final artwork
assets applied to them the first levels
you'll get to try include utopia retro
which is a circular map under path which
has more elevation and double goal where
there are two openings for each team's
goals psionics will be releasing maps as
they're created the febri update will
also bring the wasteland map over to
competitive playlist as well as a number
of other features you can also now
report badly behaving players and rocket
League is adding a gamespot community
flag if you want to get in the supercar
spirit with us Peter Molyneux suddenly
isn't retiring but he has created
goddess Wars which blends realtime
strategy with God game elements the
extension to goddess is available now
free for existing goddess owners or by
itself on Steam early access for 15
bucks your control 104 deities each with
their own play style abilities and
powers and do battle across seven
continents although not all of these are
currently available in early access
developer 22cans says there are hundreds
of levels that can be shaped to your
liking there will also be 50 unit types
and 8 God powers in total although for
the specifics of what is available in
the early access version check out our
story on gamespot one of the deity
options is brian henderson the guy who
essentially one curiosity which if
you've forgotten with that giant cube
everyone was tapping away at on their
phones a while ago goddess wars will
eventually replace goddess on stage
finally the dream team is back together
the dream team being Hideo Kojima and
horror the truth will reunite for the
keynote address at the 2016 die summit
later this month where their session is
called a conversation with hideo kojima
and p.m. adults 40 the pair will discuss
their respective creative visions and
processes and games may be a veteran
Jeff Healey will moderate while the two
have said they are interested in working
on a new game after the cancellation of
silent Hills no collaborations have been
announced kojima is also due to be
inducted into dice of hall of fame at
the event let me know down in that
comment section if you want to play
goddess wars and be sure to head to
gamespot we've got stories on Dark Souls
3 and dust 514 shutting down that is
everything I want to tell you about
today but as always let me know what you
cared about and I will catch again
tomorrow